better late than never China's
leadership has stayed away from ground
zero since the outbreak began something
that hadn't gone unnoticed by an
unimpressed public so here was leakage
Chang China's premier and the country's
second highest official after President
Xi Jingping state media was making up
for lost time faithfully documenting mr.
Lee's extensive well-wishing talk here
where hospitals are being constructed in
double-time and at the supermarket the
woman packing her bags apparently
oblivious Lee is a nice homespun touch
you don't get this close to a top
official especially envy of a camera
without careful choreography other
footage broadcast by state media has a
similar aim to show the cavalry are here
and that supplies are coming the
propaganda machine putting a rosy spin
on a difficult situation but there are
other fronts in this propaganda war wu
hands mayor admitted local government's
mistakes but seemed to blame central
government bureaucracy as a local
official I could only disclose the
information after being authorized a lot
of people didn't understand this while
officials busy themselves shaping the
narrative the situation in Wuhan is
still desperate 9 million people
effectively quarantined in what is now a
ghost town as the number of coronavirus
cases and deaths continue to rise
foreign nationals are still in the city
their government's preparing various
extraction plans measures to curb the
virus are being applied to the whole of
China screening texts like this one here
in Beijing are becoming more common all
across China the worry though is that
people might be able to transmit this
disease before they have symptoms
meaning a lot of this would be useless
authorities are keeping a close eye on
public transport in particular we passed
these temperature checks controls like
this with transport staff in full
biohazard suits would have seemed
extraordinary only this time last week
they are already part of normal life in
the epidemic Tom Cheshire Sky News
Beijing